good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be looking at today is SCP 2221
object class Keter special containment
procedures websites believed to host
instances of scp-2029 it for examination
and civilian users are to be blocked
from such websites a team of seaglass
personnel are to maintain an ongoing
search for websites and software that
require the user to agree to an end-user
license agreement and thoroughly examine
all such agreements for signs of SCP
2221 given the impossibility of
containing all instances of 2221 a field
agents will instead focus on
counteracting their effects agents
should remain in contact with law
enforcement agencies worldwide to
monitor for sudden increases in
extrajudicial violence agents are
encouraged to share information about
2221 a affiliated groups with national
security agencies in order to diminish
their political and social impact
foundation policies on political
non-intervention have been temporarily
waived in order to respond to this
threat description an instance of
scp-2029 user license agreement EU la
for short of the sort commonly agreed to
by consumers in order to use software
instances of scp-2029
or inexpensive software available over
the Internet
they are unusually long for EU la's
presumably to deter consumers from
reading to the end near the end of the
contract are three clauses believed to
bring about distinct but related
anomalous effects
clause 189 you agree that all worship
prayer obeisance sacrifice oaths
requests for guidance and or
intervention and any other indications
of divinity directed at any day t or day
DS listed in appendix h7 well instead be
directed at the serene tribune friend of
the righteous hereafter referred to as
amicus furthermore you agree that this
clause supersedes conscious intent with
regard to the direction of the affer
mentioned invocations of divinity clause
191 you agree that friends of amicus LLC
may access your consciousness for the
purpose of exerting subconscious
influence and/or temporary control of
consciousness for a period not to exceed
72 hours during any one-week period plus
216 you and friends of amicus LLC agree
that any attempt to breach or modify the
terms of this Agreement or to bring suit
against friends of amicus LLC must be
settled by arbitration in the serene
tribunal testing suggests that SCP 22 21
is not an info hazard
reading or looking at instances of
scp-2029
if the reader does not agree to the
contract it is extremely unlikely that
such a contract will be legally
enforceable in any known judicial system
however it is believed that the effects
of SCP 22 21 result from the enforcement
of the terms of this contract by unknown
parties certain classes of individuals
including mentally incapable individuals
prepubescent children and slaves are
unaffected even if they agree presumably
because they lack the legal capacity to
agree to a contract individuals
incapable of understanding the contract
such as those who cannot speak the
language in which it is written
or sleeping persons made to press the
button to agree to the contract are also
unaffected these limitations have proven
extremely disruptive to attempts to
study SCP 22 21
the contracts effects do not extend to
d-class personnel who apparently lack
legal capacity with whatever entity is
enforcing the contract SCP 2220 ones
lack of effect on d-class personnel
makes direct experimentation difficult
but the foundation has performed
extensive analysis on populations
believed to be affected by SCP 2221
individuals are assumed to be instances
of 2221 a if they have created an
account on a website or downloaded
software known to host an instance of
scp-2029 the following behavioral
changes have been observed in 22 21 s
and populations with large numbers of
2221 a's greatly increased voter turnout
and political activism instances of 22
21 a and non democratic or semi
democratic countries often affiliate
themselves with protest movements or
other subversive political organizations
instances of scp-2029 a seem
particularly drawn to positions
considered outside the political
mainstream including parties associated
with both the far right and far left
greatly increased interest in religion
and issues of religious identity
attendance of religious services is
notably high in areas with large 2221 a
populations instances of 2221 a in
Muslim countries often affiliate
themselves with Islamist movements while
instances in the United States may
advocate for an increased role for
Christianity in public life shifts and
religious practices community punishment
for deviating from religious law often
in the form of shaming is common in 22
21 8 dominated areas religious art from
these communities incorporates nooses or
patterns resembling nooses with unusual
frequency for example Christian art
tends to depict Jesus being hung rather
than crucified while Hindu art focuses
on Yama
criminals despite Clause 189 s reference
to the worship of amicus instances of
scp-2029 worshiping a being of that name
the one exception p o p 0 of 4 for 22 21
a is discussed below
and finally frequent extrajudicial
violence against alleged criminals 22 21
a populations tend to be densely
clustered so while some communities are
entirely composed of 22 21 a s it is
rare for affected nations to have a 22
21 a population of over point zero five
percent the most notable exception is p
o p 0 4 4 22 21 a which until 2013
constituted over 2 percent of the
national population events concerning p
o p 0 4 4 22 21 a in October 2012 site
614 contacts the o-5 Council to report
armed mobs attacking foundation
installations in it is immediately
apparent that these groups have inside
information concerning the foundation
they demand that the foundation handover
SCP SCP SCP and SCP and 34 foundation
personnel to be put on trial
the October attacks on site 614 are
initially attributed to the Republic of
Letters which quickly claims
responsibility for leaking information
leading to the attacks at this point the
foundation is not aware of any major
2221 a populations in and there a public
of letters claims are believed however
examination of computers at site 614
reveals that many personnel have been
using software hosting an instance of
scp-2029 the foundation shifts to the
belief that the leaked information came
from foundation personnel having been
subverted by the Friends of amicus it
remains unknown whether the failure to
find out and report this instance of
scp-2029 s-- or deliberate sabotage site
614 personnel are detained for
examination field agents from site 115
and site 61 are sent to them under the
command of site director Susan Pritchard
to observe and report on the local 2221
a population P o p 0 4 4 22 21 a due to
ongoing political turmoil in the area
the foundation adopts a strictly
defensive stance repelling continued
attacks on foundation installations
without responding in kind attacks
against local prisons are also noted
while local security forces repel most
of these attacks prisons in are overrun
by mobs prisoners that both locations
are dragged outside and lynched
including prisoners who have only
committed minor crimes such as vandalism
over the course of the next four months
changes in the religious practices of
the local Sunni Muslim majority are
observed many local mosques began
announcing the call to prayer eight
times a day instead of the traditional
five decorative nooses herbs are hanging
in doorways often adorned with colorful
cloth and elaborate patterns several
m'aimes believed to be instances of
scp-2029 a are noted to add an
additional profit Siddiq to the
traditional islamic list of prophet
when pressed for additional information
on Sadiq these Imams are confused and
denying knowledge of Sadiq by April 2013
affected communities have begun sounding
the call to prayer up to 30 times per
day with little time left for other
activities attacks on foundation
installations cease bo p 0 4 4 22 21 a
distributes print versions of SCP 22 21
thereby converting nearly all adult
members of affected communities in two
instances of 20 to 21 a but the
foundation no longer on the defensive
field agents begin to quarantine towns
inhabited by P o p 0 4 4 22 21 a and
unaffected civilians are evacuated into
foundation custody the frequency of 22
21 8 calls to prayer continues to
increase until a prayer has become
constant among the entirety of p o p 0 4
4 22 21 a between May 24th and June 6th
every known member of P o p 0 4 4 22 21
a expires of exhaustion and dehydration
the government cooperates with the
foundation in attributing these deaths
to political violence field agents
recommend waiving the foundations policy
a political non intervention in order to
prevent similar occurrences elsewhere
addendum 22 21 I recently discovered
instances of scp-2029 to clause 217
quote by reading this clause members of
any organizations listed in Appendix K 4
agreed to go [ __ ] themselves the SCP
foundation was one of the organizations
listed along with the Federal Bureau of
Investigation
the Republic of Letters and several
other groups of interests and
governmental organizations personnel who
had read Clause 217 were isolated and
kept under examination the addition had
no discernible effect
least of all a literal one
it is believed that clause 217 is merely
a taunt rather than an info hazard or
legally binding addition to the document
however supervisors are to make weekly
reports on the behavior of foundation
personnel who have read modified
versions of clause 217 okay that about
does it for today thank you all for
listening and you are all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
gets a berry thank you all very much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]